listen this this was worn on purpose
because of this gentleman yeah Bob and I
are uh in that moment we're not getting
along but we get along now
what happened at that moment
okay right uh it's what we call it it's
a pretty good movie yeah Gilmore it you
know made me laugh at least three times
I got three years that's all he needed
I'm really underselling this Abigail
Moore's a classic hey Carol I mean that
is it is you know um I definitely have
to ask you though uh I mean Bob Barker
do you remember like what was the
motivation to put him in the movie or
just because it's so different we we uh
and Bob knows us we initially wrote it
for Ed McMahon Ed McMahon said he was
busy and we we were we were like imagine
if Bob Barker did it he'll never do it
and then we sent it to him next thing
you know Bob Parker whose neighbor was
Chuck Norris at the time stop it and and
Chuck and Bob used to spar and Bob was
like yeah if I get to fight if I get to
throw punches I'm doing it
that's how it happened yeah and then the
rest is history yeah well that was a
good good time for all of us I was going
to say uh uh thank you for sharing yeah
I also want to say a sincere thank you
to both of you because for many years
you've both uh made me laugh and I've
enjoyed your work and I just want to say
thanks that's very easy to you for that
that's great if someone is actually
though this is going to be hard to
believe but if someone has never seen
anything that you've done before yeah
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and that's good that's good so
on Zohan for me that's I'll take it I
love that so much thank you I like
weighing 178 too
that's good that's not there right now
well do you want to know the number it's
at right now and it's there it's just
not it's underneath
this is a little more to it sorry yes
and how about you what what that of work
would you say this kind of say start
with friends
I don't know that's where it started
what no okay sorry no just go
with it thank you
along game Bali home no I meant just go
I mean I meant just go with it because
Maccabee that's it we get married
I'm sorry so jumping into the to the
sequel uh I I really want to know what
was it like when you saw in the script
or we're told you're going to be doing a
big wedding dance number yeah and you're
not going to be shown the moves before
you step on set scary stuff right you
crushed it I was looked forward to it
because then I didn't have to be good at
it and then I yeah that made a lot more
sense to both of us whatever they wanted
us to go and rehearse to not do it why
would we rather not know how to do it
right exactly but when I see big wedding
scenes in a in a script it's a don't you
have a little bit like oh that's gonna
take a long time that's uh well this was
a lot it's five days we shot up a
five-day wedding I'm Dan had a good time
Jennifer could not stop dancing we were
screaming cut cut she's like watch this
and just doing something cool stuff cut
all that stuff out that didn't matter
you had a good time doing it it was fun
the two of you have fantastic chemistry
together and I'm just curious what is it
like actually on set how much is you are
you guys coming up in the moment with
all how much is it um you know just
sticking to the script it's good we do a
little subscribe that we can jam on it
yeah kind of try to find something else
usually there's a there's always
something a little different take to
take yeah you say yeah yeah try to get
each other we like to make each other
laugh which is always fun and he does
all the time yeah I certainly and it
usually makes it in the movie not the
break but the line yeah yeah yeah we get
it in there uh who decided on Hawaii and
Paris as the locations and it would be
was it because one of you was like I
could spend some time in Paris let's
film there did it come was it in the
script it was kind of delivered it could
have been I think it was delivered I
can't remember if it which came first
the the the idea the script it was a
good move for whatever it was it was we
were I didn't know I like Paris so much
I I was just because I didn't know Paris
that well I I was there for junkets so I
never really knew it and then boy did
Adam fall in love with it I think you
walked every single sit block that
exists I love this beautiful so much
um I've been lucky enough to be there
and the crazy thing is every place you
go to get food is better than the last
the food's kind of 100 yep there's no
bad neighborhood there's no no uh place
I walk by that I want no let's keep
looking I was like all right let's go
there 100 I don't want to do spoilers
yeah but the way the film ends it opens
the possibility for a third yeah I know
the first one was incredibly successful
for Netflix have you guys already had
that conversation for maybe doing
another it was a movie called A Little
Romance many years ago that was shot
yes and where was it shot I don't
remember I want to say Paris or Italy
we're thinking of Paris in Italy again
for the next one one minute sorry one
man was terrible I'm gonna do my my last
question it's an individual for each of
you uh I am kind of excited that you're
gonna do something with the safety
Brothers yes yes I'm going to be in that
too yep me and Jen are gonna shoot that
are you really gonna be in it well we
just found out
because that would be amazing it would
be amazing I know say it right there
right okay that's why I said sincerely
hope that happens uh what can you tease
about the project and I'm also curious
I'm also a fan of the morning show and I
read that you're going to do a body swap
comedy with Julia Roberts that is cool
is that actually happening and what can
you tease about Morning Show yeah the
nothing's funny about yourself
um I'm kidding uh it's uh what Morning
Show is there's a lot of romance
this year and there's a lot of
um Secrets oh
that's good Danelle that will be
revealed that's good yeah and body Swap
and body swap is in the it's in the
making it's in the cooker you and
Julia's will have Soul Children that's a
dozitude forever and ever I'm all in on
it dream of mine that's a big one for
for the the for the the masses
a dinner with them last night after we
finished nice we talked about the script
it's cool it's cool I can't I can't give
you it's what you get it's in the sports
memorabilia world and and uh I know I
can't I don't know what I I just kind of
want them to decide how they want to
present it when you start we're working
on that for I think this summer this
summer I think so I hope you get a part
I really do I mean it's uh listen again
I'm saying you should 100 listen
congrats a hundred percent I wish you
guys nothing but the best